en début d'après-midi c'est 70 élèves
qui sont dans une salle pour une épreuve
une épreuve de spécialité
économique et au bout de quelques
minutes alors qu'on leur a déjà
distribué les les copies ou les oui les
copies
[Musique]
ce jeune homme Nadir qui avait juste 19
ans et j'avais fêté son anniversaire 4
jours avant ce drame tombe fait un
malaise qui a pas été identifié comme un
malaise grave à mon avis au départ c'est
ça l'histoire c'est qu'au départ je
pense que c'est ça voilà c'est quoi
c'est une épreuve de combien de temps
c'est une épreuve qui dure je sais pas
exactement mais c'est une bonne partie
de l'après-midi il est un peu
il fait un malaise et je crois que les
personnes les adultes enfin les gens qui
étaient là ils se disent bon c'est
peut-être l'émotion etc voilà il était
stressé par cette épreuve par le bac et
donc ça réagit pas trop quand il est
tombé au sol les preuves à continuer
alors l'épreuve continue il y a même des
élèves qui ont demandé à ce qu'elle soit
suspendues compte tenu du fait qu'ils
avaient leur camarades par terre qui
avait du mal à respirer avait un peu
bleuilli je pense que personne n'a pris
en fait pas juste mesure de la gravité
de la situation alors il y avait des
élèves donc qui se levaient pour aller
voir ce qui se passait forcément et les
adultes continuaient à passer dans
l'Iran pour faire signer la feuille de
présence alors qu'il était toujours par
terre et on leur disait d'aller se
rasseoir oui je pense que ce que je dis
ils ont ils ont pas pris la mesure de la
gravité ils ont dû penser que c'était un
malaise vagal ou un petit malaise lié à
l'émotion de de la
preuve de l'épreuve étudiante en réalité
c'était beaucoup plus grave que ça mais
il y avait 8 adultes huit encadrants
dans cette dans cette salle
et personne n'a vraiment pris conscience
de de la situation il y en a quand même
un gamin qui a réussi un lycéen qui a
bravé les interdits et qui a mis son
petit camarade en position de latérale
de sécurité pour qu'il soit plus à
l'aise
après il y a la Pol émique sur à quel
moment on a appelé les secours parce
qu'il y a des gens qui disent ils
parlaient plus ils commencent à devenir
bleu une élève s'est levée quand même et
l'a mis en PLS comme vous l'avez dit
nous on se disait qu'il fallait appeler
les secours ce qui nous a choqué c'est
qu'il a été laissé seul un moment par
terre
ni vous ni moi ni étions il y a toujours
un problème d'interprétation quand on
appelle les pompiers ou qu'on appelle
les gendarmes en situation de de
d'urgence on trouve toujours qui mettent
beaucoup de temps à venir alors qu'en
réalité quelquefois ce qu'ils ont été
appelés rapidement à ma connaissance oui
ils ont été appelés ils ont mis 20
minutes entre le moment où le ou Nadir
fait son malaise et le moment où les
pompiers arrivent sur place il s'est
passé 20 minutes alors il souffrait
d'une cardiopathie sévère Bruno
megardman qu'est-ce que c'est ça une
cardiopathie c'est une maladie qui
touche le cœur c'est ça c'est simple
après évidemment toutes les pathologies
qui touchent le cœur par définition on
va les appeler cardiopathies donc il y a
des maladies qui touchent le muscle
cardiaque et là les maladies qui vont
entraîner un problème de de circulation
de l'influx électrique
avec des maladies qui ont tendance à
faire emballer le coeur et d'autres
plutôt à ralentir de façon extrême le
cœur et des maladies qui touchent les
coronaires c'est les vaisseaux qui
érigent le coeur donc le mot
cardiopathie est non spécifique désigne
tout simplement maladies cardiaques
alors on sait qu'il avait des problèmes
de coeur il devait souvent rater les
cours pour aller à l'hôpital porter un
pacemaker aussi oui donc très
probablement c'est à dire que il y avait
sûrement une certaine atteinte un
certain type d'atteinte de du courant
électrique qui qui est nécessaire pour
faire contracter les cellules
musculaires cardiaques alors il a été
laissé au sol pendant plusieurs minutes
est-ce que
c'est la question qu'on se pose toujours
est-ce que si il y avait une réaction
plus rapide et des gestes de secours
premiers secours plus rapides est-ce
qu'il aurait pu survivre alors
évidemment on ne peut pas du tout
répondre à ce dossier et je ne
connaissais pas les événements très
précisément en fait lorsque l'on
développe un arrêt cardiaque évidemment
c'est une urgence vitale donc il faut
aller le plus vite possible et à partir
du moment où le cœur s'arrête vous avez
trois minutes globalement pour initier
le massage cardiaque sinon vous allez
avoir des séquelles cérébrales liées au
manque d'oxygène ou évidemment si la
durée sans réanimation se prolonge vous
allez mourir de votre arrêt cardiaque
c'est ce qu'on appelle la mort subite il
y a environ 50 000 cas par an en France
de mort subite c'est-à-dire une personne
qui ne devait pas mourir et puis qui
brutalement présente un arrêt cardiaque
non prévisible et donc effectivement ce
qu'il faut c'est mettre en place les
gestes d'urgence le plus vite possible
pour lui donner une chance de pouvoir
éventuellement survivre il y a des gens
qui font une mort subite et qui
survivent sans aucune séquelle c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs l'initiation de ces
gestes d'urgence doivent se faire
lorsque l'on trouve quelqu'un qui a
perdu connaissance et qui respire de
façon anormale sans plus chercher à
savoir est-ce qu'il est en vie ou pas
est-ce que son cœur bat ou pas du moment
qu'il a perdu connaissance qu'il respire
de façon anormale il faut tout de suite
le mettre sur le dos sur un plan dur et
initier le massage cardiaque avec une
fréquence de 100 massages sans
compression par minute je crois qu'il y
a pas besoin de faire quitte à cassé les
côtes alors il faut enfoncer de 5 à 6 cm
le sternum donc en fait on mesure on
voit où se localise le sternum
c'est-à-dire au milieu des côtes on se
met au milieu on met le lama au milieu
et puis on essaye d'enfoncer
donc à une fréquence de deux
compressions par minute alors ce qui est
important c'est il faut comprimer mais
aussi des comprimés d'une durée à peu
près équivalente donc sans massage par
minute en fait il faut pas essayer de
faire un bouche-à-bouche parce que c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui peut
rebuter un peu et puis surtout qui est
pas utile pour améliorer la survie du
patient donc il faut faire le massage et
puis surtout s'il y a d'autres personnes
autour de soi demander d'alerte les
secours voir lorsque l'on est dans un
lieu comme une gare un aéroport amener
un défibrillateur semi-automatique qui
va permettre en fait de si besoin de de
faire un choc électrique compassion pour
ramener le cœur en rythme normal
alors on a eu le témoignage de son papa
et c'est vrai que ça nous a brisé le
cœur vraiment il a révisé toute la
matinée ils sont papa jusqu'à 14h juste
avant de partir il m'a dit papa les
épreuves sont un peu dures mais je
l'aurai ce bac il voulait toujours faire
plaisir à son père
voilà et c'est vrai que
son papa dit d'après des échos que j'ai
eu il aurait demandé à sortir mon lieu
aurait refusé et c'est vrai que voilà
c'est un drame pour la famille et c'est
parents et son père était d'une dignité
incroyable et franchement ils nous ont
brisé voilà brisé le cœur voilà je vous
dis on a été vraiment toute la rédaction
était très très triste ce matin de ce
drame et d'avoir eu le papa au téléphone
qui était vraiment voilà il est
forcément très très triste mais très
digne merci en tout cas merci Michel
merci Bruno vous l'avez quelque chose
d'ajouter effectivement il y a tellement
de témoignages d'élèves qui dénoncent le
le temps trop grand et le manque de
réactivité que le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale a tout de suite
ouvert une enquête administrative pour
savoir si la prise en charge a été faite
à temps avant l'arrivée des secours
voilà et le parquet ouvert une enquête
également j'en pense très très fort à sa
famille moi je dirais c'est juste une
occasion pour rappeler l'importance des
gestes de premiers secours et
d'encourager tout le monde y compris à
les enfants des